all right next question given the
gibraltar fiasco these vaccines don't
work can we envision a realistic
scenario where establishment dems
concede the vax failure
so neither you nor i were familiar with
the gibraltar fiasco but you pulled up a
thing that um i thought there were two
paragraphs in there that warranted
reading all right yep you have to hand
it to me oh i thought you had it there
on you no you never shared it with me
it's on your phone oh my god it's on my
phone
really puts the pressure on
uh
yeah i'm a little surprised that neither
of us had heard of the gibraltar fiasco
but um so you've brett found this and
this is on rt you said right yep
gibraltar a tiny british overseas
territory sharing a land border with
spain has seen an average of 56 cobia 19
cases per day over the last 7 days up
from fewer than 10 per day in september
the rise in cases described by the
government as exponential comes despite
gibraltar having the highest vaccination
rate in the world
point of order
the rising case is either is or is not
exponential the description of the
government has nothing to do with
whether it is
i will continue quoting now
i get off my little soapbox
more than 118 of gibraltar's population
are fully vaccinated i'm sorry
all right no okay
second paragraph more than 118 percent
of gibraltar's population are fully
vaccinated against covet 19. that's a
lot with this figure stretching beyond
100 due to doses given to spaniards who
cross the border to work or visit the
territory every day
masks are still required in shops and on
public transport
um so they've got
over 100
over 100
compliance
somehow that's that's some interesting
math um but uh the rate of daily doses
is five five times what it was um before
so that's the given the gibraltar fiasco
that's the that's the background on that
question these vaccines don't work can
we envision a real realistic scenario
where establishment dems concede the
facts failure
it is almost impossible to imagine the
concession it is not impossible to
imagine the recognition on the public's
part
so i would just say you know we are here
absent concession though if the public
sorry but if the public starts to wake
up maybe because they refuse to take
boosters or whatever
how will the dumbs
what will they do in the next election
uh well now you've asked the question
what will the dems do in the next
election that's a question no matter
what true um
for so many reasons but
um
look
i don't think these people have a game
plan
i do think they're gonna keep
you know
will they admit that these vaccines um
don't work
i find that very unlikely
will they probably too late to pin them
on trump even though they were developed
entirely under the trumpet they're going
to pin the failure of the vaccines on
the unvaccinated and amazing fact in and
of itself
and they will pivot to some other policy
it will be unclear it will continue to
be unclear what their objective is
right in fact
that absolutely maddening article
from the wall street journal
makes the amazing claim that part of the
problem with the vaccines is that the
people who released them
uh botched
the communication and they led people to
think that the purpose of the vaccines
was to control the pandemic rather than
to rever to reduce extreme reactions to
covet
right
[Music]
sorry
so i haven't read this article um
if that's true
if that were true how can you have that
position and the unvaccinator causing
this and uh you can't put those two
things next to it and the mandates
because to the extent that their point
is oh this is for reducing uh
hospitalizations then the point is then
this really is a question of personal
choice
right the only argument for the mandates
if if that is actually an accurate
description of oh this is we knew this
all along this is what it's actually yes
but but then
then it's not a public health thing
right it has nothing to do with public
health right this is this is the
government trying to make sure that you
have the best chances you need this well
no thanks government i'm good
would of course be a legitimate
responsibility in that case i mean think
about it this way this is the nanny
state
and think about what a terrible nanny
state it is because
why the hell are we vaccinating children
then
that's what nannies do
if it ain't about preventing
transmission
vaccinating kids who are healthy and
don't have any risk from this disease
doesn't make any sense well so i mean
that if you're quoting that article
right if they've got some
marketing public health
officials saying
we always knew pfizer always knew that
like the manufacturer the vaccines
always knew that it wasn't going to
affect transmission
that actually changes everything they
didn't say that but
um
believe me there's no way
to square this circle right and so your
question
um about
what what will the democrats do if this
start if the public response starts to
be wait a minute i think the thing is
it's an escalator of mendacity and we
are is that a thing yeah i just made
that up no i wish i had but escalator of
mendacity yeah i like that um the point
is they are going to keep
lying
right in order not to take
responsibility for having massively
screwed this up which they clearly have
no matter what you believe you can see
that they massively screwed it up
right yeah
this this is not what we were promised
and it isn't doing what they told us it
would do and gibraltar is a very good
demonstration of that
right so you know we've had this problem
where
um
as the rate of vaccination goes up
the fraction of the people who get covid
who are vaccinated goes up
there is something ominous in that but
it's not inherently ominous because at
the point that you get to 100 vaccinated
population then everybody who gets the
case will be a breakthrough but
what this does show is that that is not
effective at controlling the disease
right
which then raises a question about
everything they've done
[Music]